The old kingdom is threatened by scar.
Scar is the evil king of the evil
brother of the King.
The king is the parrot.
The entity that inhabits the pinnacle of
the pyramid the king always has an evil
brother and you know that as well.
And the reason for that is that there is
no hierarchy that's so pristine that it
isn't threatened by corruption and scars
presented as a resentful intellect.
And that's a very common trope as well.
That's the evil scientist idea.
It's not the only only the evil
scientist idea.
It's the mad scientist it's the evil
genius God.
How many movies with a mythological
substrate have come out in the last 20
years that prominently feature an evil
genius.
It's like there's dozens of them.
There's an inexhaustible hunger for that
representation.
I mean in the last avenger movie you had
fantasy right.
He's basically the spirit of death who
is an evil genius who thinks that mass
extinction is the answer to the
population problem of let's say the
world.
Something to think about very seriously.
Well the reason for that is that this
estate is always threatened by
malevolence always.
The hierarchy can always be come corrupt
and tyrannical and that those the forces
of malevolence let's say they are
conspiring behind the scenes tend to
tilt every hierarchy towards tyranny and
the proper attitude to take towards that
universal truth is to stay in the light
and keep your damn eyes open and so well
what happens in the Lion King is that
the evil brother overthrows the rightful
king and that again is an unbelievably
common idea.
You see that idea echo throughout the
mythological landscape for centuries.
And the reason for that is it happens
all the time.
That's what happened in Nazi Germany.
That's what's happened in most of the
tyrannical societies of the world and
most societies in the world are
tyrannical.
There's always the possibility that the
hierarchies that we live in will become
corrupt and counter-productive and
there's multiple reasons for that but
they're summed up in the malevolence of
the arrogant intellect.
It's something like that.
That's it.
That's a very common idea.
That's the character of Milton Satan.
By the way because he's the ultimate in
arrogant intellect Milton Satan is the
figure who believes that his knowledge
is sufficient to do without the
transcendent to do without the idea that
there is something beyond or that
there's still something to learn.
All I know is all that I need to know
which is exactly the belief of the
fundamental tyrant
the evil
brother of the King kills the King Simba
loses his father.
Well that's another common idea because
everyone loses their father in some
sense people grow up and become cynical
as teenagers.
And the reason they become cynical as
teenagers is because they see that the
corruption of the state is sufficient to
undermine their confidence in the
benevolence of the state and they get
cynical prematurely because what the
hell do you know when you're a teenager.
But you're encouraged in your cynicism
frequently in our culture which is a
very bad idea.
No I mean even though it is the case
that the structure is always threatened
by malevolence let's say and and human
weakness.
Simba ends up fatherless and lost and
alienated from his kingdom just like
King Arthur.
It's the same story.
The king is often the rightful king is
often dissociated from his kingdom and
forced to occupy a domain that's outside
the kingdom.
And that's what happens to Simba.
He loses his father and what happens.
He's
he adopts the lifestyle of an impulsive
adolescent.
That's what happens and so he's out
there in no man's land with his useless
teenage friends doing nothing of any
good except living for the moment.
And that's the nihilistic retreat from
the corrupt state.
And no wonder and you might say well if
the state is corrupt why should I
participate in its maintenance.
Why should I do anything that's useful
if all I'm doing is furthering the
development of a corrupt state.
And I would say the message in the most
pathological university disciplines the
activist disciplines.
That's exactly the message that they're
particularly putting out to young men
which is you live in a corrupt
patriarchy and that means any attempts
that you make to further yourself in
this life as an individual with regards
to your family.
Another corrupt patriarchal institution
with regards to marriage or career that
all that is is furthering the corrupt
patriarchy.
Everything you do that you think is good
in the productive sense is actually
doing nothing but contributing to this
catastrophic tyrannical patriarchy very
demoralizing but also opens the door for
you to be as useless as you possibly can
because and there's always a temptation
in that direction because it's easier
and you can justify it by saying well if
I did anything productive all I would be
doing is furthering the dominance of the
corrupt system anyways.
And if you haven't met people who think
that way then you haven't met very many
people because that's an unbelievably
common way of thinking and it's an
excuse but it's also a logical reaction
to the confusion of competence with
power.
That's part and parcel of the
collectivist landscape.
So Simba grows up so to speak gets older
at least playing this impulsive day to
day game.
Rule seven in my book is do what is
meaningful not what is expedient.
And of course symbols lifestyle outside
the rightful kingdom is nothing but
expedients it's impulsive pleasure and
that lasts until until what until his
old girlfriend shows up Nahla and she's
been dealing with the catastrophe of the
state and maybe that's because
women
the demands of family fall heavier on
women at least initially and so they're
more sensitive to the catastrophe of the
state.
Nahla shows up and says December
What the hell do you think you're doing.
You're useless.
I liked you when you were a kid.
Here you are.
You're completely useless and
everything's falling apart and the state
has become corrupt and there isn't
enough to eat and there's things that
need to be done.
And he falls in love with her of course
probably because she criticizes him and
and then he's deeply ashamed of himself
because she rejects him because he's
useless.
And so she should reject him because
he's useless.
And if she didn't then he'd never figure
out why he was useless and do something
about it and that's when he meets his
father.
Remember there's an initiation scene
there.
The wise old baboon who is supposed to
be a fool and in the early drafts of the
movie guides him down underground so
that he can reflect upon himself which
is what he does in a pool down in the
underworld and what he sees reflected in
his own face is the spirit of his dead
father mature face symbol looks like
this right.
He looks like a deer caught in the
headlights.
The animators have done a really good
job of capturing that naive and sort of
rotten old adolescent innocence.
You know that's that's outlived its
utility and but his father has a very
set face which means he's integrated his
aggression and he sees his father in the
water and then he sees his father in the
sky and his father says you've forgotten
who you are Wake the hell up.
Grow the hell up.
There are things to fix there.
There are things to fix there's
responsibilities to take on and so.
Symbols rather shocked by this encounter
and decides to leave his false
adolescent paradise and to go back to
the catastrophically demolished state
and he takes his friends and he sees
this place that where there's nothing
but starvation and cruelty and
malevolence and tyranny.
And he fights a battle against evil and
he reclaims his kingdom and as soon as
that happens the rain falls and the
plants grow and harmony is restored and
that's fascist mysticism by the way.
So it seems to appeal to a very large
number of people.
Given the popularity of that movie and
what is that.
What's it called a responsibility.
It's a fundamental called a
responsibility.